[Musique]
non loin de notre dame née sur la rive
gauche la rive intellectuelle passé
autour de l'église saint-séverin à
l'antique église de l'université un des
derniers îlots du parc du moyen-âge à
résister plus pour longtemps sans doute
mais tel qu'il est encore avec ses
maisons vétustes qui ont souvent besoin
d'être aidés pour rester debout avec
aussi ses souvenirs de villon de
cormeilles de verlaine le quartier saint
séverin est devenu après montparnasse
après saint germain des prés le quartier
à la mode
[Musique]
on
la rue de la huchette ou bonaparte
habitat constitue en quelque sorte
l'artère principale de ce quartier cher
à huysmans et toujours doux au coeur des
clochards il y à la détonante échoppes
comme l'épicerie d'ali baba qui ne
veulent pas son nom
[Musique]
au demeurant on trouve ici ou là un peu
de tout et l'on ne s'étonnera pas de
pouvoir acheter n'importe quoi à la
boulangerie sauf du pain mais c'est la
nuit que la vie commence
il n'est pas peu près ici un restaurant
chinois tous les trois jours
ionesco continue de mobiliser la fiche
du petit théâtre où la même troupe le
révéla voici huit ans dans les rues
étroites les voitures de luxe occupe la
moindre place disponible car les boîtes
sont nombreuses
ici c'est le pianiste noir memphis slim
qui officie pour les amateurs de jazz à
l'étagé en dessous c'est une troupe qui
dévoile au public curieux et avides de
révolution sans danger un théâtre
d'extrême avant-garde ailleurs c'est
l'exotisme des dîners au son des
balalaïkas
[Musique]
votre cas et caviar d'un côté souper
quignon de pain de l'autre c'est l'image
même du quartier saint séverin quartier
cosmopolite aussi dans cet îlot du vieux
paris l'amérique l'asie et l'afrique se
retrouve à l'endroit même où furent
logés au xvième siècle les ambassadeurs
du pacha d'alger se déroule chaque nuit
les rites des danses orientales
[Musique]
quant aux jeunes ils ont ici leur cave
au caveau déjà ouvert au temps de la
révolution
[Musique]
et là toute une jeunesse résolument new
en ligne se retrouve la danse et l'amour
sous les yeux imperturbable de saint
séverin
[Musique]